the funny thing to me about all this is
you know when people get
mad that it's like it can never happen
here
we've been hearing it over and over and
over again and i have
i have to just say it's like i say this
before but i'ma say it again to
everybody who's you know
did i make all this up it can happen
anywhere
am i the one who who hacked twitter and
said it was a cyber attack
these are the conversations happening
among journalists we just saw this
executive order from trump
yep we just saw the you know in the past
month a strike group in china
these things have literally happened and
security experts have said
we fear this is going to happen in 2015
the atlantic wrote thucydides trap
is going to lead us into a war with
china and since then we've had
article after article after article and
you know what really annoys me
the stupid people who keep saying it'll
never happen here no matter how many
times security experts keep saying it's
starting to happen
it's almost here wow that looks like
it's it they're like
this is not real you're just you're just
you're just fear-mongering
well we just got attacked today
i just got hacked and and listen even if
we take it at face value
that was a bitcoin scam that's the
scariest proposition you know why
you know what's less scary what it's
actually comforting
if this was an attack from china you
know why
how come because that means if this was
just a bitcoin scam
some random [ __ ] was able to take obama
and biden's twitter account
and steal them from jack dorsey and he
couldn't do anything about it
if that's the case imagine what china
could do right
if if some random idiot was able to
fish biden and then tweet a stupid
bitcoin scam
and that's like the damn you know about
the the three gorgeous
damn is is like on full exp like it's
all of them are open and it's flooding
everything downtown
where it down like wuhan everything's
flooding downtown of the dam
in china right now so they're probably
struck 400 million people live
live south of this why is the dam
flooding the city because
the the dam is is can't hold back the
water anymore
so it's it's at its peak so they have
all of them open just blasting water out
right now
and who knows what's gonna happen like
they they're probably stressing
they that i i don't even un know what
the implications of it
well but it's happening so china's
definitely stressing about some stuff
there's a big story now brewing in
africa i don't have the details pulled
up
but has something to do with a dam on
the i think it's the blue nile
so there's the white and the blue and
then they merge into the nile river
so egypt is at the end basically
and in ethiopia i think it is they're
building a dam which is filling a
reservoir which is restricting water to
egypt which could slow it down
egypt's starting to get worried because
they're reliant on the streams that come
from these other places yeah that's true
and apparently china is backing the
project
that's at least some of the reports that
i've seen so
yeah it says they failed to reach an
agreement today is and was our chinese
involvement well i'm gonna check
yeah see if this see if you can find
anything on that yeah man
you know earlier today we were just
chilling we were skating
adam threw down this line and that was
it that's all that's all that was
while the world was seemingly burning
down on twitter and people were
screaming out these hacks
we were just chilling in the backyard
cool breeze came in temperature dropped
several degrees like the lows in the 60s
right now
and we're just skating and everything
was just just gone
just gone away but the more i talk to
people
the crazy thing is like there are people
around here who are starting to get
worried and get scared
yep i was just talking to a guy who was
telling me he's putting together like a
big
rv rig to gtfo yep and i'm like
like where do you hear this stuff why do
you think that right and who are these
people who think
nothing is happening that everything's
going to just be like
be nothing like there are so many things
barack obama could have tweeted
that would have just ended the world
that's a good point
what what people need to realize about
this this twitter hack
they took 136 billion dollars off of the
stock market in a matter of
in a minute with one tweet from the ap
imagine what would happen if they were
able to take control of donald trump's
twitter account
and then he tweeted something like
oh man i want to be careful i mean any
any
could be anything yeah there's countless
things we could probably say
in this place there what if he just
tweeted we you know the federal
government
arrested you know person x uh from
during the riots and has just summarily
executed them in an offshore rig
let this be a warning to the far left
you're next right what do you think
would happen if it would be crazy
yeah or or if like joe biden announced
that
you know we can't wait till the election
it's time to move in we're taking it
yep we're ending it now before it's too
late
there's a lot of things they could tweet
especially controlling that many
accounts
the other thing too about the about the
hack was that you could do a search for
the terms
and you could see that it was actually
widespread non-verified users people
across the board had been had been
hacked by this
[Music]
yeah man but i don't know should we
should we be more optimistic is there
is there a better way to look at things
is there a different way to look at
things
are we being are we are is it because
we're just watching the news all day
that we get wrapped up in this stuff i
mean
i i'm i am the optimist i am ever the
optimist i always always try to be
you know look at the lighter side of
things but that doesn't mean i'm not a
realist
and i think realistically this is
probably the closest we've come to war
in my lifetime
i mean like an actual world war like
there's the war in afghanistan exactly
you know sure
in the 90s uh what was it the uh desert
storm
right right so it's like you know i i
wasn't really political
and it didn't really hit us here in
america
where this is
it looks like they are undermining every
facet of our country
and they're in the minds of the youth
and that scares me also
you know i have a lot of friends of mine
that i've been having these long
conversations with
and uh a lot of them are mad at me
and are blinded by this
confused um
like call to to be virtuous essentially
you know they think they're being so
virtuous by doing what they're doing
and then you know it's so hard to to
really just
say all of the things that i've learned
over the past five months
you know like i just want to be like go
watch every single episode of
of tim cast irl and you'll get a little
hint of
how how i know all the things i know
because i've been doing nothing but
conversating
you know with people who who know what
they're talking about and i've been
looking into things
you know but seeing this like even i
mean this
is crazy this is the whiteness the
whiteness thing is
it just it's not white culture it's
it's civilization yep
hard work that's how humans got here do
you think that's how
humans are still alive right now because
of hard work because we worked hard to
get here did the japanese not farm
right did they not farm do do they not
work hard dude japanese people work
super hard every single country works
hard
to be the good citizens of every country
work hard to
to do well and get a job and work and
and and thrive
everyone wants that this is getting rid
of all of this
is just it they just want to wipe out
humanity that's the way i'm looking at
it
but it's only affecting the u.s
racist yeah they are they make
commercials and they laugh they have a
word bite soi
it means white left it's basically their
version of sjw
that's true they mock it's funny to them
yep it's funny to us too
to a certain degree yeah until it until
they start
undermining the the roots of what it
means to be an american
when people were warning that the stuff
in colleges would one day reach
industry yep a lot of people in the
media were like hahaha
there is hope i was reading an article
from cook political earlier
and they said that donald trump's path
to victory is to hammer down on cancel
culture
because when it comes to the rioting
people are sympathetic
to police brutality issues but when it
comes to cancel culture the average
person is terrified yep that's true
donald trump has talked a bit about it
you know when they when they pull down
christopher columbus and stuff people
start getting
you know they start giving the side eye
like wait what's going on but cancel
culture isn't a direct a direct attack
on regular
people exactly what's biden going to do
if donald trump says
your supporters are are attacking the
jobs and the businesses of regular
people trying to get them canceled right
what's biden going to say we'll f those
voters
sure he can and then they're going to be
like well then f you too yeah exactly
these these these people he's putting
himself in a really
like in a corner because he he's
catering to them
i watched his speech the other day he
sounded like he was talking to a room
an empty room but it regardless of that
it sounded like he was trying to say all
the stuff that
that is trump's platform without saying
it yep
yep it's like by american how are you
you're he's trying to cater to both
sides thank you thank you
there you go thank you yeah exactly that
was uh our new sound button by the way
yeah apparently we've had streamed that
we could have done it the whole time the
whole time
ready ready for this i'm gonna alley-oop
you okay for which one well biden
it seems like he's really trying to
cheat
an election good teamwork there buddy
cheating election we'll get better
you're a lion dog
face pony soldier you can try me you can
try me biden
but i see right through you man you're
lying dog face pony shoulder
i ain't afraid of you button we
officially went from being very serious
the world is ending to
sound bored mean clips of greta tunberg
yelling at me
i regret nothing so
according to this cook political thing
if trump starts coming up with this
messaging that
under joe biden he will be too weak to
stop the far left he's opened the door
and you will you'll lose your job you'll
be kicked out of school
and it's happened i forget the uh
there's an antifa
uh woman who was talking about how
we need to vote for biden because he's
malleable
yeah he will he will uh bow down to
the mass the masses and our current
president won't
she straight up said that yeah and that
is
true that is a frightening thing because
i i believe it i
i agree with her she's right on that and
that's why we must
vote for trump what's obstinate times
100
is there a word for that i don't know
immovable
yeah man if trump doesn't want to
trump doesn't do it yep it's like that
guy is
well beyond stubborn joe biden just goes
what huh uh
oh what am i supposed to do
i've got this list here yeah i got stuff
of reporters i'm i'm allowed to talk to
uh is this person from the ap here oh my
gosh is that what he did you didn't see
that
straight up he said he's the person from
the ap yes he was like is this a
specific person here
anyone i don't know who it is i'm just
this is the list of approved
people i'm allowed to talk to maybe
maybe the whole bit is to make biden so
non-threatening that the whole thing is
just for and against trump
that that's literally what it is yeah
people are voting for biden
so biden's purposefully just
milling about and falling asleep the
orange man bad
rhetoric is is flaring it's flaring wide
and and i've well you know what a little
uh
shine of light for everyone out there
for every person
that has complained that has yelled at
me that called me names that is
yeah on my facebook page uh page i said
i'm voting for trump
i want to have let's have a conversation
about it i'll explain to you why
we can talk for every person that has
been
crazy coming at me there's been more
hitting me up privately going you're
you're 100 right
i agree with you not not just privately
posting on the post too defending me
talking about he's he's right you know
especially
my friend from venezuela he's like i
lived in venezuela
i'm a proud american citizen now i don't
want it to happen here and this is
what's happening
and everyone just was like yeah whatever
they're not mutually exclusive and it's
like are you kidding me
do you you are you even and then that
that same person
sent me a bunch of stuff like here well
read all this stuff and it was all
you know allegedly he trump allegedly
did this
his you know everything this and i was
like well here you know just
you know check this out too no no i
don't want i don't need to read
propaganda
it's like they're brainwashed
this is what i tell people do you think
but not everybody you're on the
side of the good guys is it the good
guys who refuse to learn and read and
and and understand no so if you're
someone who says
i won't read that isn't that kind of
what the bad guys do
absolutely now now do you have a problem
with trump supporters who refuse to uh
to to learn the truth they say yes
yeah yeah i want everyone i want to know
all sides of it
all situations i want to read everything
about these right these lefties will be
like these these these trumpsters don't
even read the news it's like no
no they're reading everything they're
reading all of the news it's actually a
fact
oh that's okay this is that was just my
assumption yeah but it is a fact
it's a that makes sense uh conservatives
according there's at least one survey
that after the site that i haven't
pulled up but um
conservatives get 60 of their news from
conservative sources and around 30 or so
percent from liberal sources
okay moderates are about 60 liberal
sources and 30 conservative
okay and liberals are like 95 liberal
sources that's crazy so the left yeah
this
this came up in the uh joe rogan jack
dorsey thing i did where jack mentioned
that leftist journalists don't follow
conservatives but conservatives do
follow leftists
yep and this is seen easily on twitter
you'll see someone from the daily caller
from the dc examiner
they'll be responding and tweeting at
you know fox vox never goes the other
way
these journalists don't follow
conservatives so the crazy echo chamber
all the way on the far left gets worse
and worse and worse and crazier and
crazier and crazier yep
absolutely and then
we get this weird ideology yep and we
start swirling the drain man so that's
where we're at
look i know a lot of people who started
like so listen gold is skyrocketing
yep property in montana idaho iowa
wyoming skyrocketing
yep this is the weirdest thing to me
when people are like
you know it's not going to happen you're
overreacting i really don't think
anything's going to happen
you know trump's going to win it's fine
and i'm like then who are these people
of means
with a lot of money right who are buying
all this gold right now yeah
who are buying all this property in the
middle of nowhere
why why is who are these people of means
in new york city who are fleeing 500 000
people
and why are they doing it why it could
it be because there's been mass riots
for 40 plus days
i was talking to a friend and they were
like but the riot stopped a long time
ago
nope they just tried to set uh the
courthouse on fire last night
in portland what's going on yeah and
there's a video going around where the
guy's waiting at the door with the
hammer pulled back
for the fed to walk out they had a state
of emergency last
last week in in utah and georgia state
of emergency in in georgia and utah
by the end of the week and so i'm just
i'm curious
you know i guess these people they don't
read the news no these people that are
buying all this property are leaving the
cities
they're take their a billion dollar
industry was taken to arizona from
seattle
we had uh oh the billion dollars how
many how many people left new york city
finance company how many people have a
million half a million people just up
and left
by i i personally have a really good
buddy of mine the the
place he worked at closed for months and
and he was like i'm i'm done
him and his family moved to their their
ups to upstate
this country has changed dramatically
more than it's ever changed
you know and it's changed more in the
past month and past two months three
than it has in the past 30 years you
know probably and all these
the democrats that have done all this
craziness
are just making people rethink democrats
there's a lot of people that will vote
that voted trump but still hit democrat
then how how is how are the polls skewed
the way there are all these journalists
we talked about these the polls though
it's like it's it's and then but look at
all the people on the left where do they
get their news from each other yeah who
do you think they're polling
each other of course and then not only
that
hey who are you voting for i'm not gonna
tell you i'm voting for trump
because cancel culture is live and well
you know for most
you want to tell a journalist you're
voting for you want to tell a journalist
you're voting for trump let's go
away are you voting for it i'm like uh
bob biden
yeah not everyone has the the you know
the luckiness to work for someone like
you
like me i'm talking about myself i can
gladly say
i'm going to vote for trump i think
that's it right there i think that's it
that's the one piece that's been missing
from this why would a trump supporter
lie to a pollster
because they're not a pollster as far as
they know they say hi i'm calling from
the economist
hi i'm calling from abc news right can
you tell me who you are voting for
uh uh uh biden uh i don't know who you
are
yeah well you saw a journalist wants to
know who you're voting for yeah yeah
right right like i'm gonna tell it
because look
i think people i think one of the
contributing factors correlation
causation between
you know why someone vote for trump is
if they understand the news has been
lying deceptive manipulative
agenda-driven and so you have people who
aren't avowed trump supporters you'll
never know their trump supporters and
they know the media is full of it
now then maybe they're trump supporters
because the media is full of it and
they've seen the media lie
or maybe it's because they were trump
supporters in the first place and trump
calls them fake news they don't trust
the media
but then the media calls hi i'm calling
from the washington post we're
conducting a poll
i'm a journalist you know trying to
figure out how people are feeling can
you answer some questions for me
uh sure how do you feel about president
uh president joe biden
that's great yeah do you want to tell a
journalist so they can publish your name
dox you
spread for their antifa friends or
whatever no but no nobody wants that
but i think i think you gotta you gotta
be careful because that could just be
wishful thinking
for all we know i i think most trump
supporters
are die hard trump supporters most
yeah does that mean there's enough to
overcome
the gap in in the polling every single
person
who who is going to vote is going to
vote
they are going to do it i i haven't
voted in 12 years
are you planning on voting this year i'm
planning on voting me too yeah
i'm absolutely going out and voting and
i'm talking about who i want to vote
for because i think it needs to be
spoken about like people need to talk
about it
and not be afraid to talk about it i'm
not afraid
i'm ban me facebook bring it on
i don't care cancel me go ahead i'm okay
with it
because i'm still going to be saying
what i'm saying you're you're in that
position right now so
uh you're you're at like what 32 000 on
twitter or whatever
yeah i guess so you're in this you're in
this position where you're you're
growing fast enough where twitter's
obviously gonna start getting worried
about
like uh oh this guy's gonna get a lot of
followers
this this this hippie vegan skateboarder
guy who just decided to vote for trump
yep and i i i say this i know it may
stand conspiratorial but
a video went up of adam talking about
how he's decided to vote for trump and
it was like liberal votes for trump and
it was deleted several times
in two days millions of views why was it
deleted several times
so look you can call it a conspiracy
whatever i'm saying the bias is real
we've seen it and your videos are taken
down
yep so once you get to a certain point
where you have enough followers it
becomes very difficult for them to
remove you because it would cause too
much of a pr headache
but you are in that danger spot yeah
where they're like hmm
maybe we should ban him before he gets
too big it's too late
it's too late people would talk about it
yeah he got banned
yeah of course boom they'd be talking
about that liberal guy said he was
voting for trump they just nuked all of
his stuff white no idea
well i'm announcing it right now if they
do you know exactly why
because freedom of speech does not exist
anymore
well if we must maintain freedom of
speech
period if conversation go ahead if trump
or however you know we see twitter
youtube facebook whatever get
nationalized
because the risk to our security in this
country is too great
maybe not nationalized maybe that's but
a lot of people are saying it but you
have a combination of factors that you
don't see necessarily in say the
financial institutions
but we we have completely insecure
systems so there's got to be some kind
of law they've got to lock this down
they've got to secure it
yep we cannot allow this to happen again
we're lucky they fired one across the
bow it's a warning shot
and they're saying heads up we need 230
reform we need a rebalancing of
political discourse in this country
we don't have it this is one way to do
it it would bring back it would bring
the first amendment right into twitter
and not only that these these tech
companies lack
the ability to make substantive money in
the first place
outside of algorithmic manipulation and
trying to sell ads
so maybe we're better off with a public
service
that is twitter we need it and it is
you said social media is becoming the
new town square
that happened a long time ago definitely
it is absolutely the town square that's
where people talk
they don't call each other anymore they
don't yeah halfway don't even text
each other much anymore it is all social
media
what's going on let me go share pictures
with the family it's like
i half of the people that i i said i had
a tweet a couple weeks ago i said would
you miss facebook if it was gone
the only people that said yes it was
because
they would miss talking to their
grandmothers or their
seeing what the family was doing and all
the only thing i could say to that was
call your grandmother call her up
she would have vision she would much
appreciate a call from you
than you tagging her on a facebook page
so she can see your your kids
i'm serious go visit her go visit your
grandmother
i need to go visit my grandmother
i don't hit her up on facebook i don't
go on facebook
facebook has just become where uh older
people are
maybe yeah i don't see a lot of younger
people on it anymore i don't even use it
i use messenger
i don't i don't really use i barely use
messages you know what i go on there now
to talk about
my political views yeah and and start
fires
start fires that's what scene figurative
fires yeah yeah
i use messenger for like five people i
don't even know why i use it
i don't know i haven't yeah i don't need
it facebook's just gone
twitter is a political conversation it's
a big dumpster fire and everyone's
jumping around up and down
very exciting nothing else yeah yeah
yeah youtube has become very important
youtube is a place for people to listen
to podcasts
yep i think youtube in terms of
podcasting is way bigger than itunes
i've i've seen i've seen trust you on
that i don't know i've seen the numbers
for itunes
for some of the biggest podcasts in the
world and i'm like it's not
it's barely worth it it's like i get it
it's worth it to a certain degree you
know it is
that the journalists use it true
journalists are all sitting on itunes
this is the worst thing you know what
maybe maybe twitter shutting down the
blue checks was one of the greatest
gifts to mankind
well they're back i know vox and the
guardian are laying people off
and i'm sorry but i'm not sorry
i'm so i'm i'm sorry to the industry but
i'm not sorry to these people
yeah you know we we need good journalism
but right now journalism has become
a bunch of woke you know you know
it's that meme of the dogs the super
ripped dog
journalists in the 1930s the mafia might
kill me but i'm gonna get the story
anyway and the next one is the frumpy
little dog saying someone called me a
mean name on twitter
i need a one month vacation yeah yeah
yeah and full benefits
well the barry weiss letter you know
it's like even
even the moderate you know who hated
trump she hated trump right oh yeah
totally it was like
anti-trump moderate foreign was or how
to spell it
right that was brutal that was brutal
not even allowed to be
moderate anymore they're coming for the
liberals
matthew iglesias the co-founder of vox
is
is tweeting out these like help i've
been kidnapped messages
oh my god yeah these cryptic creepy
messages dude
matthew iglesias co-founded vox okay
lefty publication
and he tweets things like i have an
opinion but i'm not going to say
anything wow
he's basically saying help help i'm
being repressed literally
he's sending coded messages out what's
happening they've silenced me
i have words i can't use them well you
said it best
many times tim if all the people that
were fed up with cancelled culture that
were
if they just got up and said were we've
had enough
it would end because there's a lot more
of them
than these people trying to cancel
they're just they're just being bullies
i don't believe in their majority no you
don't believe it i don't believe in it
i need evidence before i believe in
something that's a good point and so
it's like what i see so far is like
a dude on twitter will go the silent
majority and it's like one guy in a room
yelling and i'm like bro you're by
yourself
there's nobody around you nobody's got
your back if you walked up to me
and said i'm i'm gonna get in a fight
with you yeah and i'm like okay
well here's my leftist collectivist
buddies who won't shut up
and then this other guy goes well the
silent majority is on my side where are
they
i don't see them here hey so i have a
question about that yeah do you think
that it's possible that you don't see
anybody really interacting with people
who say we're the silent majority
because
like the algorithms are kind of stifling
them no
well did you hear about the uh the
protest in front of trump tower against
blm
yeah yeah did you hear about the taking
over the entire
brooklyn bridge the the the anti-blm
ones the the pro police defense defend
the police march
took over the brooklyn bridge that was a
lot of people yeah that's a lot of
people
they're starting to stand up i'm seeing
a lot of defend the police
protests out there and it's good to be
fair it's happening to be fair
in terms of you know when we see the
left they're in cities so they're hyper
concentrated
true and the anti you know the counter
protesters would be in rural
areas where there's no real easy way to
gather true so that's true
but on social media the inverse should
be true it should be easier to see more
conservatives
complaining now i understand not when
not when the companies
yeah that's what i was going to allude
to it's like they're banning the people
who want to speak out that are talking
the other side of things
and maybe in the cities there's no real
resistance
maybe it's just maybe they all left
already
i don't know man if a silent majority
screams in the woods and there's no one
around to see it do they even exist
sure they technically do but are they
going to change anything
no of course not if if the majority of
people show up at town hall holding up
blank signs
and you know let's say the majority
let's let's say massive million two
million people in new york
the majority went to when we're we're
all in the streets holding up signs and
the signs were blank
what would the city do
i don't know i don't know either what
are they approaching no one's holding up
any signs
all they're saying is who streets are
streets not even saying no
they're not saying that either well that
doesn't really say anything so i feel
like that's pretty
neutral these people are just you know
and then and then one person is inside
in the middle of it goes we're the
silent majority and you're like okay
then you look over your left you see a
group of 100 people smashing windows and
you go
make them stop what do they want that's
what's happening
that that's why i'm not entirely
convinced silent majority really exists
i guess we'll see won't we we will see
man we will we will
but uh i i can't i think it was matt
walsh who tweeted this
he's a daily wire right yeah he i think
it was him i don't want to
fall asleep tribute because it might be
spicy but he said something like don't
waste your breath on people who won't
even stand up for themselves
if you won't set up yourself why should
i why should i bother defending you matt
walsh is pretty spicy that might have
been him
fairly spicy sounds like something he
may have said you know my my tweet
i tweeted out i said i just posted it on
facebook i'm voting for trump
i'm just looking to see what happens
there's over a million
impressions on that tweet it's my
largest tweet ever
oh yeah everybody's like good for you
proud of you we're standing with you we
got your six
welcome i'm glad you opened your eyes
thank you thank you
good for you we're proud of you 12.
you're not alone
that that was prevalent heavy i'm still
they're still tweeting
on it and honestly i appreciate all of
you thank you you know it means a lot to
hear that
when i am putting myself on a platform
where i am right now speaking
talking about these issues making it a
direct
you know choice and i'm standing by it
and i stand by it and there's
and there's a risk that you know here's
how cancel culture works
pepsi puts out a new flavor watermelon
pepsi yeah they immediately get
inundated with like 50 tweets
50. but they see in their in their
twitter like all these people saying ew
gross oh this is nasty so nasty
and they're like oh no we're getting
inundated with messages what do we do
quick get rid of the flavor meanwhile
you had 7 000 people
like wow watermelon this is great yep
same thing could be happening to you
you don't he's a good point you go on
twitter and you're like go trump and
then
all of the die-hard trump people are
like yeah and so you're surrounded by
this group
and then when you zoom out with that
drone shot it's like a tiny little
cluster and a massive empty park good
point
yeah sure yeah i could see that
yeah so what do you do you know other
than just i'll tell you what
i'm going to go vote for trump exactly
stay true to that's what i'm going to do
don't listen to anybody else if someone
says you're going to lose don't do it
someone says biden's going to win
you know vote for him ignore everybody
trust yourself trust your gut
not only don't wait i'm not just going
to vote for him i'm going to keep
telling people
why i'm voting for him and everyone kept
trying to to
well why are you going to vote for him
why are you going to vote for him
because of you're you're basically a
racist now
and i was like okay well no i'm not
here's all of the things that i'm
super impressed about that i had no idea
what happened
still still nobody has responded to me
one person hit me up today giving me a
bunch of counters and all i read all of
the articles
all of them were allegedly this happened
allegedly this happened
allegedly this happened and then he
spoke about
these neo-nazis and i'm just like ah
like i watched his speech myself go
listen to his speech
work listen to this check out this
documentary
check check this out no no i don't need
to read
i don't need to read your sources
because my sources are correct
well let me tell you for the few people
that were out there that are
that i'm talking about right now there's
a lot more people that are reading the
things that i'm reading
and going wow he's not so bad he has
done a lot of things
because i believe that and i've seen it
it's the best way to describe trump he's
not
that bad he's not and if sure he's he's
blunt if that was brash you know here's
the thing if they were fair to him in
the press
then i'd be like he's bad if they were
fair yeah but they're not fair right
they're not and so
but the standard by which they judge him
is just totally is total bs it is he is
nowhere near as bad as they say he is
yeah the whole stop making me defend
donald trump thing as well yeah that's a
great
great meme great news making me defend
the man and now
i mean ultimately just even like you
look at this guy look at that look at
this
this is just this is you're a lion dog
face pony soldier who's voting for that
guy
are you kidding me are you nuts i'm not
voting for him it's like you have your
choice right now we're in a plane okay
trump's flying it now we can take that
guy out because you don't like the way
he talks he's on the intercom going like
yeah there's a lot of dumb people back
here a lot of
stupid people and you're like oh this
guy is so annoying on the intercom
and then you've got a guy sleeping yeah
you really want to hit the sleeping guy
and talk about because this other guy's
got a potty mouth
yeah i'm sorry dude trump's an alpha man
yeah he is
love and there's a lot of people that
that alone
pisses them off well here's the way
because they don't like alpha males
here's one of the ways i describe it
you're in a schoolyard and you've got
some bully problems
okay you got you know bully china and
they're they're they're they're
pushing around hong kong or whatever
yeah and then you're sitting there and
you're like man we got all these bullies
all over the place and they're causing
problems for everybody you got kim
jong-un
kim jong-un was like the little dude
standing next to the big china dude and
they high-five as they like pick on hong
kong
and then you're like i can choose who's
going to represent me
who do you want to stand behind the guy
who's asleep in a wheelchair
or trump who's making fun of people
mocking them
and pushing people around he goes listen
i'm a mean guy on this playground but if
you stand behind me i won't bully you
i'll bully them
that way nobody bullies you you're gonna
be like okay all right i'll be i'll be
your bully
right i'll be yours basically he said it
yeah i'll be your bully that's it
he's our bully you can call him a bully
and it's like yeah well american
the american people a lot of them know
that
yeah they they looked at hillary clinton
they looked at trump and they're like
trump's gonna push everybody around he's
gonna he's gonna like
you know i was in an airport and this
guy said i've told the story before but
i was at an airport and the bartender
was pro bernie and the guy
next to me was pro-trump and they both
agreed that trump was gross
and it was funny to me because i'm like
i was like you're voting for trump and
he goes oh yeah
yeah i wouldn't invite the guy to my
house for dinner hey
but the economy is great you know so
where the money is and i laughed and i'm
like activists
actually rag on people like that for
saying things like that that the economy
is more important the money is more
important
but i'm like i don't think they realize
what he's really saying he's saying that
we're succeeding as a nation right why
would you vote for the guy who's going
to burn it all down just because he
sounds nice
you wouldn't you'd vote for the guy
who's mean he doesn't sound nice to me
he sounds
creepy well i mean like crazy at the
time bernie sanders
okay all right yeah we're gonna give
everybody bernie sanders seems nice
health care for everybody even the
people who don't live here you live in
the philippines for healthcare you live
in antarctica for some reason
for healthcare venezuela venezuela
healthcare
healthcare just come on through the boat
is open
joe bion goes look fat bernie
bernie sanders said free health care to
anybody who crosses that border
you're lying dog face pony shoulder
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you